what
Mike how are you pretty pumped to play
Titanfall 2 Rob what's up I am as well
my name is Rob this is Mike we're
playing Titanfall 2 uh we've been
waiting to play this
all week and uh
yeah I'm uh I'm excited to get right
into it I'm going to get a anti-titan
weapon
here so yeah it's kind of a bummer we
have to keep you know leveling back up
but who cares this game is so fun yeah
um the progression I mean like yeah the
first game had the burn cards this has
like a full progression system and uh
it's fun yeah
man uh sweet amp weapons so you're going
with the pulse blade I that's like one
my least favorite abilities oh yeah I
don't know if it's like my background is
like just playing a lot of Shooters at
well I mean I know you do too but yeah I
like it I just like knowing where people
are all right cool ion is that a new
skin for
ION
uh yeah I I don't think so I don't what
so you have factions uh which gets you
on like unlock you're working for the
good guys you get um the only yeah the
only thing I've been seeing those uh
show up or like have whatever the impact
they are is like whenever you intro a
game right it's like that character in
the drop ship like go get them well you
also get those Advocate gifts which are
specific to each faction once you level
their faction up okay um let's do
variety uh playlist yeah do that yeah
that sounds good that which includes a
bunch of good game modes hopefully we'll
get like Bounty Hunt we'll show
everything last Titan standing bounty
hunt pilot versus pilot yeah and there's
even a weird new one called um Coliseum
mhm that uh I have not gotten a chance
to play and that could be fun to look at
and that is basically a like one
onone fight to the death uh versus mode
where like you are on top of a platform
and you just what do you just have you
have like Titan weapons and that's about
it and you just go at it it's either the
uh that pulse rifle or whatever it is
that shoots those orbs or it's the uh
it's anti-titan laser
yeah uh and also I mean I know that you
know this game comes out tomorrow Friday
we're playing on 4 um it looks like a
lot of people are playing that's the
most people I've seen in those Network
lobbies there that's a lot of people
yeah The Advocate network is the main
the default we may even want to get out
of this variety mode and try something
more popular uh I don't know if people
are even playing this okay we'll have to
see um cuz you know you should see you
should see some numbers going down I'll
try bounty
hunt that's a fun match yeah that's
that's definitely like one my go-to is
for sure
sure there we go
yeah went down to
two two mhm if this doesn't work out we
might maybe we'll do like a single
player Mission all right um You and I
have both played the single player it's
super F oh look at all these so a lot of
these are characters from The Campaign
right yeah he is she is you can't
trust all for the sixf bark Barker or
Baker what was it Barker yeah isn't he
from the life is
Expendable again I'll be looking at uh
chat if you guys have any questions um
hopefully we can just get into a game
ASAP
mhm two out of
10 I even wonder if we should change the
um data the data Network yeah but I
wouldn't know which one to be
on maybe like an East Coast one I think
we're on like Salt Lake
City let's try
that I try like I don't know
try the Ping gets real bad
there Singapore try yeah try
that no okay so just yeah go back this
just do um do like orgon do
Oregon
we'll get there
eventually you played uh last night uh
did not get the chance last night no
yeah I near
die was going I wanted
to so yeah the only other Titan I
haven't unlocked is tone which is feel
like a fairly popular Titan I like tone
a lot yeah
yeah it's kind of like a Call of Duty
variant almost eh not really I mean it's
like a semi-automatic rifle with
Explosive Rounds then you get those it's
cool like you don't have to hover your
reticle over them to uh to lock on you
have to actually hit them or use that
sonar pulse and then you get the missile
launcher lock on go around corners right
um his his primary weapon is pretty
beastly it's got some distance what it
like 20 mm Cannon
yeah um which feels like actually one of
the original weapons I think so here are
your uh I made the Game Spot one so did
I oh I I made one called it
spot
um I don't know I mean you you're we're
in the right one that's like their you
know their uh let do that default Data
Network
okay uh say we give it another maybe I
don't
know two minutes five 10 minutes we just
get going actually show this game
or do like attrition
maybe so yeah if you're turning tuning
in turning in tuning in we're playing
Titanfall 2 trying
to be multiplayer
online yeah CU like most people were in
variety pack playlists last week right
but that was for like pre-review stuff
timefall 2 comes out
tomorrow it's legit it's it's a
tough It's really probably one of the
hardest years as far as Shooters go to
pick one yeah like there's been like
what six this year like that were I mean
like OverWatch doom and then battle
borms around the same time if that was
something you play a lot um I did not
but
um yeah Titanfall 2 Call of Duty which
seems super interesting as far as the
campaign what they're doing with that um
and uh yeah Battlefield one obviously
it's pretty spectacular yeah all right
let's try one
more Bounty bounty hunt I mean I feel
like it's either bounty hunt or
attrition
uh where's Skirmish though oh go
back there's no Skirmish hm
weird maybe that's in the
variety the smart pistol is in the game
um I think they approached it probably
in the best possible way it's in your uh
it's a boost so essentially if you
remember burn cards from the first game
they've been kind of just like re miixed
into this fashion where it's your boost
ability which is essentially the same
ticker um timer uh mechanic of like a
Titan right it's like your pilot's alt
your alt yeah so the first one being all
I don't think we're in right now let's
uh let's do a single player all right
should we just do the beginning so we
don't spoil as much or no the beginning
is not that all right yeah I in my mind
the uh unfortunately I haven't like I
mean I've be in this campaign like three
times now but like I think probably the
this is the coolest one but I don't want
to we're not allowed I I don't want to
show it right um uh there is like it's
just it's too good there are a couple
levels in this game that are just too
good yeah for I mean like you want to do
a heavy spoiler
warning in either one of these how about
one of
these I say uh into the abyss or this
like even earlier on okay oh wait no
that's the uh that's like platforming
yeah do you think that's I think that's
fine uh I think you could just do the
first chapter and then maybe we'll cut
it uh as that as this level is kind of
unfolding okay um well for those
watching this is a mid Game mission so
might be some spoilers just so you
know yeah that's a good call I'm going
to change this dream title um yeah uh
sorry you know multiplayer looks like
it's a little uh finicky right now we'll
give it a shot after we play maybe I
don't know 15 10 minutes of uh single
player yeah just to keep could also like
I don't know roll promise anything
potentially do another multiplayer
stream when servers are definitely going
like tomorrow or later on today
all right I'm going to jump into this
again for those just joining this is a
mid game single player Mission so I'll
try to skip as many cut scenes as
possible eh I don't
know major Anderson went this way it
could be a shortcut to the rendevu point
I recommend we
proceed controls transfer to Pilot yeah
so campaign's pretty cool you can swap
on the fly when you unlock
new uh Titan loadouts obviously this is
earlier in the game so this is the
default Expedition that's like kind of
from the first game but a multiplayer
variant what is this place accessing
files oh there we go Unown scor right
there right what are we doing here
BT so yeah collectible quick you mind if
I collect it for you Rob I do not your
account I've got it many of times so
thank you
any reason to replay campaign um I'd
say I'd say there are a few
reasons uh one
being Collectibles if you're want to go
that route
uh is copy
over second go ahead is not responding I
think our
militi he's got to be headed your way
kill him understood Ash out yeah so for
background like we took a so here here
would be my he is a war criminal wanted
by the militia commonly employed by the
IMC blizard was responsible for the
death of my previous pilot Captain
lamosa so you saw the dialogue prompt
there at the bottom you get two choices
typically one is more humorous the
other's a little more sincere uh but a
couple of these um they're they're
pretty
engaging a couple of them oh [__]
actually go into
like I'd say like up to three branches
of of of a different conversation so
playing it again like um and you know
this this happens throughout the game
you kind of find yourself having a
different experience honestly like you
know the writing is is is fairly good
for what it is um it's simple I'd say
you know you even say the same about the
narrative the story is very simple but
it's neat to play it again and have uh
like a different
conversation yeah able to recognize
scores from multiplayer if they play the
beta or anything it's like a flame base
Titan my favorite Titan
personally I'm still BT 7274 in the
campaign but I'm using the scor load out
right uh anything in here
maybe engaging
hostile oh you got the uh shotgun pistol
the uh I think that's the standard when
you start off the mo oh I mean but yeah
this is the MOs beak I'm just saying
like like yeah do you like this pistol
yeah uh multiplayer it's unreal it's
actually kind of op in my position uh
opinion it's got a lot of range for a
shotgun
pistol especially if you have like stem
and you're just sprinting around yeah um
where is his
shortcut was I just in the right spot
already I'm sorry what did you just ask
right am I going the right way oh here
we
go control
initiated turn on subtitles we probably
should have done that you want to do
that real quick yeah take two
seconds there it is righted bottom
yeah um yeah Collectibles are just hey
man you couldn't ask for more
appropriate use of that thermite trap oh
I love that
all right I think it's called incendiary
trap so that's the problem with Scorch
is you you can still get hurt by your
own fire yeah um uhoh oh [__] so this is
probably one of my favorite levels we
won't go too far I think the the
spoilery stuff or the heavy spoiler
stuff comes like toward the end so a
couple of these levels have like
chapters cuz they're some are longer
than others um watch this so we'll get
to a point where I think it's it'll
it'll be safe to
leave
oh whoops uh this is on PS4 that's
correct the yeah the the Collectibles
the helmet Collectibles really don't do
anything you just kind of um you know
it's
just I don't know just to say you you've
done it yeah you're
switching yeah so you can switch on the
Fly and this like like Mega Man [__]
really fun in campaign especially later
when you have all of them and then
you're fighting bosses and stuff right
and yeah and to uh for anyone who is
looking forward or plans on um playing
the campaign I highly highly recommend
even if you are like find yourself a
casual um shooter player shooter player
I would say 100% play on Harden at least
play on hardened the next the highest
difficulty is Master which like I've
been playing it's tough get a little
Titan battle coming up yeah right here
it's tough but like you you it really
brings out the Titan battles like you
were required to get out your comfort
range and like change up you know Titans
in order to combat other like bosses who
have you know one of these load outs
like a Scorch you're not going to be um
a ronin necessarily cuz he's going to
lay all these traps in front of you you
want to maybe be a Northstar like you
kind of are uh dancing around with the
loadouts in a really unique way um among
other reasons firear to play play on
Master the other one what I would say
is the game even tells you uh and this
is very much Titanfall is you always
want to be moving always parkouring and
the game even says like on a death
screen if you die like you got to keep
moving cuz you're harder to hit so like
Master really brings that out
um and I just yeah I mean you agree too
like regular was just like a little too
easy
yeah control the pilot
all right so Tone's pretty cool yeah so
you can lock you have to hit him three
times or do like three actions to lock
on oh [__] put that
down but I actually want to go back to
Scorch cuz I can shoot around Scorch is
so fun who's kidding me oh this [__]
[__] you I always think about the grunts
like it'll be just one grunt trying to
shoot you and you're just like man I'd
hate to be this
guy
you're gung-ho I'll give you that but
you're no I'm saying just like the guy
like yeah yeah yeah you're gung-ho dude
but you're
done W you're dead I'm not even going to
shoot you ah damn it yeah I
am all right oh actually I'll show for
people who don't know like SC just moves
I can show him what his flame Shield can
do on the grunts yeah fry him yeah see
these guys got the right idea this is
what I'd be doing I be running yeah
until
you ooh three Titans all right let's go
oh this is where I us scor all right
here we go hey what's hey I got to tell
you
something
I think the other thing that's really
neat about the campaign is that
it's there isn't a moment you know
people have you know have had their
doubts about the length of it you know
I'd say even on Harden it took you what
4 hours 5 hours to play which come on
come on
might upset you at first but it's so
packed there isn't a single moment where
you're bored or or what you're seeing is
lacking it's just so tightly packed and
Polished that
uh I think that also makes it so
worthwhile got BR so you got another one
yeah this level they give you two two so
brute and Expedition are not in
multiplayer they're kind of like this
one's like more like a first Titanfall
Titan and the brute is kind of a mixup
of a few things uh right Expedition and
Brew are kind of like it's like
Northstar mixed with uh ion I guess the
vortex
Shield right it also has this weapon
this quad rocket isn't in the
multiplayer whatsoever so it's it's a
pretty cool weapon you you know if if
you aim down sights it's a single rocket
um your primary fire is just like yeah a
spiral of rockets close range short
range kind of another shortcut trust me
um right pilot it's so weird like right
when you kind of might be getting sick
of like Titan or Pilot combat switches
to the other at the perfect times yeah
absolutely and I also like in the the
difficulty in this game they don't amp
up the enemy Health they just make them
more like stronger so everybody's a
glass Cannon including yourself yeah
it's not like they're overpowering the
enemies they're just or they are but not
like healthwise this part is pretty
funny cargo lift
activated watch watch this
unfold I have in here mind no you just
got to keep moving uh I love that a
shotgun yeah I'll go this so fun to use
it's like it's probably one of the
weapons I like stick with the most I
assist
yesu
lo I located aity
load Roger three on Route out my Titan I
cannot free myself
Cooper so let's play I'd say just a
little more of this just a little more
yeah half of this chap chap these are
pretty funny down here too like BT's
internal dialogue going on yeah you get
a lot of story out of these things which
is you
know it sounds corny but it's they're
enjoyable to read you know what I mean
like they're not like boring pieces of
writing
yeah
uh pilot I need assistance looks like
the automated Security in this
place that's work for
us so yeah and like on a higher
difficulty too like you you find your
cloak to be
so so precious
like it's like it's really meant I feel
like in campaign it's really meant to
like fill in the gaps of when you like
fail parkour or like are not doing so oh
[__] uh
yeah uh what we
doing ah here we
go the story dialogue choices are
they're not like outstanding I would say
that they're just you can usually use
both of them if you're quick enough a
lot of times the choices y oh I I just
used both of them the last three times
what do you mean both of them you press
up and he says that dialog option then
sometimes you have the option to do the
other one sometimes you have the option
of like well like the game will just be
like you know you're doing both choices
oh yeah uh sometimes it does not let you
do that
right some of these helmets are pretty
tough I found uh some of these helmets
in really like bizar uh areas like again
uhoh yeah again like there is some of
the levels are more open than you would
ever think like there's a lot of like
nooks and crannies that are meant to be
explored which is which is why you would
play it again in my experience like have
your first run enjoy it and then kind of
go back and see what the whole campaign
has to offer use different Titan in a
different spot exactly yeah what are we
doing
here careful pilot uh I'll go with this
this this gun is cool it's like an lmg
that like ramps up yeah in a really in a
very uh enjoyable way like it sounds so
Coolified
ass
nice this again I don't want to show too
much of this level but it's what would
you like to dool as destroy it SP he is
being dealt with this facility isil
I'm sure I can take advantage of that
fact if I have to Ash that place is not
your bloody playground I'm not paying
you to be clever scle that place if you
have right [__] didn't mean that oh [__]
that was a little no nobody moot taken
down inem line there may be a common
exit I recommend you follow the flow of
the
platforms pilot this facility is
extremely dangerous watch for crushing
hazards on the line
oh [__] so like these shielded
grunts you have to like often times wall
run and get behind them and
it's oh those guys are
nasty uh yeah yeah usually wall Runner
like throw a grenade right behind them
and then turn around cuz that Shield you
can get multiplayer it rotates
slowly pilot I'm being taken down in
assembly line there may be a common exit
I recommend you follow the flow of the
platforms pilot this facility is
extremely dangerous watch for crushing
hazards on the assembly
line those guys explode
[__] shootting me from up here what
is happening up there it's above
you no
maybe there you
go yeah this game has boss battles
they're you know essentially Titans and
they're at the end typically of each
level there are nine levels generally
oh close
one U all right so I got to wait until
that happens and then jump on
[Music]
it some of these parts remind me of
portal in such a great way
yeah
nice did you know supposedly the [__]
the um the thermite throwing star can
blind Titans in multiplayer oh really
yeah
like you could like that that makes it
so much more worthwhile to carry them to
like you know throw one at a Titan and
then Rodeo him or something
yeah
uh-oh get
there damn
it you actually might be playing this on
regular no oh dang yeah it's on hard I
could I can put up the master no I'm I
was just
curious [__] those guys are tough the
turrets like you can't shoot them
without grenade espe yeah you have to
yeah explosive uh weapons
or [__] yeah dang wish I had a frag
there get through the next checkpoint
and try multiplayer again hopefully it's
working yeah one more uh beat few
minutes we'll
switch coming up there I wonder oh
there's a dude up there
nope it's not a bad place to be though
right above everybody yeah there's a
weapon up here too so there's a lot of
like kind of like weapon caches that are
hitting around EPG is so
good
uh [__] those
turrets all right one more time don't
stay
put I'll get that gun and get out of
there I just want to take that turret
out then I can do
whatever yeah Master can be pretty tough
they uh like even just like the weakest
grunt can uh one hit melee you so like
you sometimes I'll wall run and just
like drop down and find myself in a in a
squad and I'll you'll just be
dead
nice uh for those of you T tuning in
this is the single player campaign we're
going to play just a few more minutes of
this and we're going to give multiplayer
another
shot we're playing on PS4 this Titanfall
2 comes out
tomorrow
3 I don't know what he
should here we go oh those weapons check
your legs son all right here we go all
right after
this ooh oh get on get on what being
taken through an area oh
man I don't think I got a checkpoint
there yeah I I really recommend playing
on
Master actually I'm going to get it up
there try it out one more one more beat
here in this level
[Music]
yeah is the single player tight uh uh I
love it i' i' legitimately like I'm on
my third run playing on Master it's so
fun keep moving yeah it's really welld
designed what the hell are they building
here it's just you're just entertained
like
thec like I I almost love that it's that
short you know what I mean like At first
I was like you I left initially wanting
more but man you just look back and you
go like that like some of these levels
are so unique and it's weird how the
game feels so good it feels so good and
that's what brings me the brings me back
to Titanfall is just like wall running
and the mobility and the movement is
[__] [__] what should have gotten off
before that this is
Master yeah see it like it gives you
prompts right like it'll tell you like
wall running boosts uh your
speed you got a cloak and find it your
cloak is your in between um but yeah the
the single player is make that jump just
so jam-packed entertaining like each
level is uh super
unique to say the least I like I feel
like any
more uh any more description of it would
be like spoiling it like there are a lot
of mechanics that are
introduced um they're just really
memorable yeah all right one or two more
yeah
however I I would
say the single player like you wouldn't
buy this game just for the single player
you know like that would be a mistake
unfortunately oh those ticks are going
to ruin you
bye get out you get out of there I don't
have ammo what do you want me to do this
is the anti
Titanfall yeah well okay I'm not I'm not
doing that anymore fine um should I try
multiplayer now yeah let's try it all
right I don't want to spoil too much
this Mission no nor do I it's probably
my second favorite Mission uh in this
game um all right as you could kind of
tell something is being assembled yeah
and it's fun to play that for the first
time the dialogue choice is actually
probably the weakest there cuz it's like
what is this place BT he's like I have
no idea yeah yeah it keeps happening oh
man yeah BT is pretty funny sometimes
all right all right so cross our fingers
try bounty hunt I
guess and I actually think we should
just wait like I think I did this the
other day and it took some time but
um that'll
eventually get into a match
huh once we get into a match we can just
stay in it oh for sure yeah you're once
you're in that yeah that group which is
great what's a game that's not like
there's a game the other day I was
playing like you keep get thrown out
like a fairly recent game you get thrown
out Battlefield do
they no Battlefield you stay in the
match like the other day I was just
playing a game it was like you just get
keep thrown out of like after every
match there's three we're getting there
we're getting there this is going to
happen
[Music]
all
right while we're waiting I can uh show
some customization I guess hell
yeah so I like pulse blade oh you know
you should show probably my favorite and
I can't wait uh this game has a lot more
progression in like longevity of like
you know cool unlocks uh I think the
Cosmetics are like one of the things I'm
most looking forward to you should show
like northstars um Cosmetics so you get
like essentially war paint like it
reminds me of like a World War II planes
go down to the um that one look at that
freaking smile can you imagine doing
doing your flight core someone just
seeing those teeth like those teeth uh I
just love it so what does that mean
unlocked after Northstar regenerations I
like prestiging I think it's like
prestiging when you get to level 20 yeah
look you get to level 20 and then you
unlock these when you start over like
Prestige oh oh okay so you know it's the
prestige and then these two are from
like that's looks like apex predators
when you reach a certain level this
looks like damn that's kind of neat it
it seems it seems like the prestige is
only with the Titans I don't know if you
can prestige in like as a pilot I mean
you probably could but it's cool to have
that separate Prestige right like we're
at four people getting there oh that's
gross that's neat oh
maggots there camos
um some of them are pretty sweet looking
mhm so yeah
that's I like that the Titans have
separate progression that's pretty sick
the yellow just yellow's
cool 20 pil
kill unlock that's
cool oh that's cool I get so connected
these Titans I actually like the
aesthetic stuff
yeah
yeah 10 Titan kills
Northstar
and then obviously yeah you get currency
you can just expedite
unlocks it's coolest looking
one um do they all have the
same that's
tight that's
tight
Cupid L A lot of them do pertain to you
know like the type or the I guess yeah
yeah overall aesthetic of the Titan
right like a cupid you know obviously
Titan can fly an actual [__] Samurai
right there that's sick that is
tight o look at that shark one one down
to the
left yeah that's cool he kind of has a
shark that's so cool because you know
his nose kind of jets out there this is
an
iceberg oh no it's like like a the Grim
Reaper an
owl
I want to play so bad what is happening
four
people there might just be people a lot
of people in matches seven like 800
people in this network what do Legions
look
like it's a
spider Legion is harder than I thought
that's cool legion is probably the most
difficult time to use between like that
long range and short range yeah you're
that's tight
was that yeah you're you are switching
between that long and short range and it
can get tough like just because like the
battlefield so frenetic like next thing
you know you're up close and personal
with a ronin you got to take the time to
switch to
that firing
mode I like scorge a
lot psycho cat or three
people
Portal 2 skins would be cool some of
these guys definitely remind me of the
portal guys what was the one there was a
battlefield one uh the Red Baron one if
you had played Battlefield one yeah so
tomorrow if you've played Battlefield
one you should have that uh like the
world war one it's like all red it's
like the Red Baron all red Iron Cross
but I don't it might be a camo because
it's like the whole body right it might
be a camo and the Iron Cross could be
like the face yeah we keep going up to
four people going down [__] um could
play another single player Mission no
let's keep trying man uh
go maybe try like
attrition yeah this is the network I'd
want to
in how many people are playing right now
in this network that's the thing 382 I
mean I I kind of feel like we should we
should change up the data
centers I don't that like I didn't have
any like when we had the betas and this
was a problem the open Beta like
we try Anar Point quick I like Anar
point a
lot but I feel like you're going to have
a harder time getting into this than
anything like like Bounty Hunt I don't
know yeah I don't think changing the
data center is going to help though I
mean those are
like hard point or I try variety maybe
wonder if I could just can you join one
of these
guys
no I wish I would tell you like
who is
playing right like unless you're unless
you were friends with
them
uh I think you should try variety
Maybe
damn damn is right I think she changed
the data center that's not going to help
that's just that that was literally for
the specific purpose of playing before
the servers went up data centers just
are like already tuned to be like your
best bet like by default I mean I could
try but we're not going to
yeah what a
bust I could just play like part of
another single player mission for now
while we're
here make the most of our time I
guess uh what do you guys think in the
chat this is
unfortunate um why don't you try
attrition for a little bit
longer I'm just I'm just judging off
like how many players are what seemingly
like looking to join yeah Patrician and
bounty hunt I think are like your best
try bounty hunt one more
time uh if you guys want to see more
single player or if you guys are oh
there we go all right well that's we're
good we eight though we should be able
to jump in can't you do 4v4 we'll get it
uh I think so I just want to get in the
lobbies so once we're in oh once we're
in we're in if it drops I'll be so
pissed
seven
seven yeah we're waiting for a game
we're doing it so tonight the server
should be like flooded with the new
zealanders and Australians I would
assume tonight is this Thursday
yeah cuz I assume everybody's playing it
now are like I don't know YouTubers
press still yeah cuz there's no Early
Access for this game there was for
Battlefield I saw today that uh all DLC
and content for Titanfall 2 post relase
will be
free cool
updates
sweet it's pretty pretty wild yeah
especially if they I mean this game is
tailored to just release another Titan
and completely change things up just
like OverWatch releases like I don't
know Sombra if they do that yeah I got
to get back into OverWatch too this game
makes me want to like this and OverWatch
like compliment each other so well in a
weird
way kind of I mean like both hero Shish
all right come on one more person I
think we can jump
in4 uh Mike Mike V1 976 wants to know is
this better than the first game yeah
100% uh for a lot of reasons I mean like
these Titans themselves are not just
load out I mean they have loadouts but
like these things uh but they're not
just light medium heavy now they're like
these actual Heroes so ion's like a
laser focused you know he's got a laser
laser mounted shoulder rif uh shoulder
Cannon he's got the chest Cannon Scorch
is more flame attacks North Star like a
sniper kind of uh jump jet missile
launcher ronin's up close shotgun sword
ninja or Samurai uh there're they you
have to like learn each Titan they're
easy to learn but I hate the phrase that
you know like easy to learn difficult to
master but then like the more you play
the more you realize you could do with
these Titans like uh someone grapple
hooked me a Scorch and I put on my flame
Shield disintegrated yeah um but also
like the progression itself increase the
longevity it's not just burn cards
anymore it's each weapon
upgrades um boost I mean you get like
these tactical alts not the alt there's
eight all right we should be able to
jump in now uh someone wants to see the
Nitro skin for
scorch all right skin or I believe skin
Nitro I don't know don't have it is
it noseart or
skin
I I don't know what Nitro is I keep
hearing
that like I've seen I've seen that in
like imagine it would be like light
green right or something but maybe I
don't know I I'm not sure what Nitro is
someone was
asking I don't know that's pretty sick
that
skin try it again this one yeah that's
sick like the later ones aren't just
camos they're actually like how do you
get that last one black market is that
like a pred here we go here we go here
we go oh yeah high five thank God now
I'm gonna oh I can't wait to play now
all right uh I made a cool cool cool
cool this a good map too what are we
playing I don't even know a game mode
bounty hunt Okay Bounty Hunt's really
good to
show um select Titan here we
go select Titan who should I go with
I'll go with my boy wait scor is a guy
right I don't know they they
uh yeah all right all right all right
all right eliminate the remnant Fleet
forces in the area beware of rival
factions but keep your eyes on the
prize Remnant Fleet reinforcements
inbound
what's going on
[Applause]
here oh yeah got a pilot kill
whatever yeah Scorch
is oh you're in the thick of it uh
Scorch is so good for this mode yeah and
just you know the premise of this mode
is to breake up money whoa you are
really in it uh to rig up money and then
you have to cash out at certain here we
go here we go moments of the game you
get killed you lose half of your Cash
Call in your Titan Scorch is awesome cuz
he do
such a large down uh amount of area
effect on like Grunts and stuff
yeah so okay here we go yeah at the end
of each grunt
wave I love this lob and [__] over this
one for those of you joining us we're
playing Titanfall 2 on PS4 game comes
out
tomorrow my name is Rob this is Mike and
we're playing this dope ass
game oh nice got so then you get half of
whatever body they're carrying he had a
lot man he had like yeah he had 300
bucks punch
him what oh you [__] God damn it I
that's unfortunate all right should I
get rid this 75 bucks there's no point
they used to happen a lot in the first
game that's the first time I've seen it
yeah all right so there's my anth weapon
your Boost it's kind of like a yeah like
a burn C oh
[__] you [__] damn it he's just all
right yeah if you guys have any
questions do put them in the
chat um yeah it comes out tomorrow it's
Qui over it out all right so that Titan
is the new Bounty and this tone dude
right here is you a jerk about things uh
no you're not able to change the voice
of your Titan uh
generally of the six half of them are um
female half of them are
male they all sound pretty damn cool I
think Ronin has one of the like coolest
ones we take a look at him he's got this
very dark like we are stronger together
Titan we're stronger together pilot all
right so blade is the Titan Bounty right
now I don't know where the pilots are
one's
Titan [__]
good damn
it
you can't go prone in this game they got
a lot of
Titans oops didn't mean to come out the
open like this all
right that Bounty over they have the
advant wow they're screwing us up the
enemy has claimed a
bounty okay sure I they're all in TI I
should go way at the
bank once he finishes killing me oh he's
almost done he
close so these B yeah you have to get
out of the Titans to deposit your
money I believe the max player count is
V8 is that right for bounty hunt it's
5v5 I believe um yeah depending on the
mode I'm just kiding we don't have
anything I'm just going to get rid of
this got
sniping um that's that's actually a
pretty good question I'm I'm pretty sure
um regarding Titan
batteries yeah they don't there aren't
any that are that are spawning on the
map I'm pretty sure they in certain
modes in last Titan standing there's a
few there's a few on the map that's
right uh that's exactly right so but
generally you get uh batteries from um
Titans that are killed or you Rodeo a
Titan and you remove it and then you can
put it into your own Titan by entering
it or you can hop on a friendly Titan
right and give them basically like an
overshield uh removing a battery from a
Titan removes uh some of their health it
does damage and then exposes like their
core so then you'd have to basically
Rodeo again and drop like a grenade in
there in order to uh do then expect uh
exponential
damage H
SP really want to just get money in here
we're getting smoked yeah so attrition
has Bots it's just like the original and
bounty hunt does
too come on come on come on come on this
is how much do I have 235 it's not bad
we're actually we kind of came back that
last round a little bit your Titan is
ready uh I here I don't want to come up
show them your Titan uh I don't want to
get in yet I want to deposit this once
they're open good call save it up then
go just [__] Scorch on these [__]
that's a
ronin don't want to go near
him I got two scort switch my Titan
before I call it uh can I switch it now
yeah that was in he just took decent
amount of
money uh yeah standby for
Titan
all right going to go smoke those dudes
[__] now wave completes
now all right
whatever so now you just go to these
yeah station or upload um take their
money from them Banks Banks and yeah you
just defend them prevent them
from there's a ronin I don't want to
actually I'm I like Scorch against Ronin
I like that match up oh this is going to
be tough
shot that looks pretty
good did D just
go you can definitely play as a female
in this game
uh it's as easy as come on finish
switching yeah and both pilots and
Titans have like weapon skins and um
overall
skins Titans
being uh the one that has like also a no
skin that you can put a cool design
on don't take that
Bounty got it yes
nice finish this guy now oh you got it
get a trap on oh he's done he's done one
more shot one more shot oh
yeah all right [__] who the [__] else is
all right I really got to eject I'm
[__] out of here oh [__] I meant to
eject yeah you got to tap
that tap that I went too early
tooing hostile
Titan where'd he go where' he go I got
to deposit this it's not a ton but
something man I I I wonder
if I'm not even sure if uh batteries
drop when a Titan is killed I in
campaign they do uh in campaign they do
Fu going maybe that's where I'm getting
confused Titan's still alive yeah that
Ronin just following me try
[__] yeah my Titan is still a lot
damn I'm just going to is he actually I
don't think he
is no he's not o all right that ronin's
almost
done yeah you got to get ready to
cash I got to wait for that
bounty's together
team where'd he
go ah it worries me I don't know where
he
went
the enemy has claimed a bounty all right
here you go yeah hang there [__] they're
going to be
coming atast someone knows how to get a
j you hear
that ooh he's so done shoot
himit damn that shooting on my part oh
there we go he's dead
I don't think that team knows quick
quick quick quick
quick they're probably at the other
one
yeah we have a good round good wave we
re catch up definitely and this this is
a good money making
wave right here which just like strict
grunts that's my Titan at right now a
little more than halfway just got to
kill a bunch of grunts speed that
up so yeah uh Titanfall 2 comes out
tomorrow
yeah we're playing on PS4 multiplayer
bounty hunt
Jesus bounty
hunt [__]
[__] I'm way too close to this [__]
right now they're their pilots could
come
in you got some cash bring right
now
so there's a uh look at that battery
there you should pick that up I'm
getting your Titan after this wave my
Titan oh for the shield yeah yeah
totally uh where'd it go to the right
there it is uh I don't like it damn it
you [__] not you that dude waiting
for damn I shouldn't have told you to do
that you lost no more no more tell me
that play lost halfy [__] well if I had
cloak uh yeah I'm not
using I'll take them both on oh [__]
yeah oh you got these
guys
[Laughter]
oh
flame
Shield behind
you yeah ask for that one yeah well you
see the take
down well that felt good all
right
go what do you think you'll play this on
like PS4 yeah yeah I made the most
progress in that
already oh that's so cool to see from
the
ground that's how you do a job did I
kill him oh no he's ranked up right ah
they're going to they're going to take
this oh there's a guy on
top
nice oh look at that getting some money
out of that thermite
star is he is he on auto Titan this guy
that's Bounty oh okay got show them what
you got a they're going to take
it nah
nah the enemy
has damn they could win right now if
they just deposit that [__] I'm just
going to go steal some [__]
ah there's no point in doing this
but camp out wait for
them yeah there are customizable weapons
um where'd he go he die as you
progress uh you know as you level up you
can unlock weapon slots automatically or
you know you get currency after every
match like I don't know to upwards to
like $1 away from
winning upwards to like I don't know 10
credits whatever the currency is and
then you can kind of amount that and and
unlock whatever you'd like early so you
know level 10 you can get Scorch or like
Legion automatically or you could spend
the like 20 credits and unlock them
early so it's you know you kind of
unlock um whatever you'd like early uh
depending on what you really want just
drop [__]
B standby for
Titan
nope
ooh
the you did
it all
right oh this guy's not going to make it
oh he did oh he had a
battery o ow oh there we go we got
Co level a few things up though yeah I
mean this this mode you're in you thanks
this mode like yeah I feel like some
people just don't know what they're
really supposed to be
doing
cool yeah we deposited the most
money all right I'm going to stay in
this mode though so we don't have to mhm
so there yeah you're going to level up
things automatically like each level
you'll get so based on those merits you
get like your challenge and then you get
like a set number you need for each it's
not just an experienced
person that's
good
oh nice over core that's one of my
favorites yeah where you start your core
ability you're like ultimate for your
Titan starts 20%
earlier look at that look at all those
things those green arrows
green long range do I want that so you
can unlock tone right now
yeah extra ammo put a new paint on that
look at that uh
um bam people also want to see Ronin um
[Music]
okay yeah I typically either go overc
core or extra Dash I like being
mobile sick what's this
camo what the hell is a Coliseum
ticket that pertains to
I guess what the hell what was that have
a Ki gift oh
Banner n that's kind of badass um
another one
where I don't
know all right sweet that was quick all
right cool boomtown's a good map that
was from the beta but it's really
good Boom Town uh yeah I can be Ronin a
little
more
stick with this load out for now H let's
see what you got
the of this
fight they're all me that so I got that
I got the stem shotgun I'll do that the
one like funny to watch it's so funny to
watch but it's also perfect for uh CTF
yeah for sure as soon you grab it just
get the [__] out of you are just the
ultimate like flag Runner rebound like
wall running and hitting that thing
is reminds me of angel dust
[Laughter]
yeah totally not that I would
know again those of you tuning in we're
playing Titanfall 2 multiplayer bounty
hunt mode on PS4 the game comes out
tomorrow I think roughly 10 hours right
if it comes yeah if is some reason it's
up T night it's super fun oh this guy's
closed oh finish
him [__] so yeah steim oh
you yeah that's why you got a shotgun oh
double Nice dou kill nice double kill
[__] ooh let these dudes oh [__] so
ticks I hate are using against them or
using them I hate being use them against
me uh they're prox
is like pretty generous I feel like you
just like will turn the corner and when
those things goes off and you're just
done they are really slow that's the one
yeah they they uh are
slow where's this dude
coming what damn it damn it I was right
next to the bank he just took what like
not that much 75 for me
Ronin
oh this voice guy right behind transing
controls to manual operations he British
sounds so good of course he's British
are in control operation sorted his face
God he sounds got a nor right next to me
too uh do your smoke I don't have it
you're right War enemy pilot attack so
yeah you can get like a did the does the
phas war get him off me he took your
battery whatever [__] um yeah there
are like you know uh Titan kits where
you can like start off with an electric
smoke in order to like combat those
rodeos from enemy Titans uh or you just
as
you um as you play as a Titan you kind
of like to now you got it right now it's
left on the uh d-pad and you can engage
that stuff
right
Eng
Focus all
right once I land just get ready to
go I love it oh [__] the enemy has
claimed so yeah you're you're extremely
fast and you take um less damage when
you have that stem engag
faster I have money right now
n
[__] where's the closest
[__] I'm not in a good spot to go to
the banks right
now
yep anybody camping
camping nice oh we're
winning
cook
it
uh-oh that should kill him good timing
now I think that just removes his his
shield and does a maybe like a third of
his
damage but he was at that's what I'm
saying he was at like nothing he was low
yeah I don't
know
o Dude I can't go outside right now keep
pushing pilot we're barely
ahead I can't get the [__] outside damn
he almost had you
too
Tak down
there yeah the smart pistol takes the
form as a
boost uh which is again like kind of
like your pilot ultimate ability
that that um operates as like a ticker
yeah all right I um I forget how many
rounds it is uh but it rep it also
replaces your secondary weapon and I'd
like to say you get like four or
five rounds of like you know maybe three
three shots
yeah fle which is I don't know people
you know have always said like oh that
gun was really overpowered in the first
game which I think is fair yeah um so
it's kind of a I think it's a an
appropriate way of like handling it in
this
game
oh man I can't you know I actually uh I
actually really like CTF in this
game I've never I I you know I used to
be like back in like Halo 1 days like a
CTF ftic oh my God uh that was like my
last F last fond memory of like
CTF I don't know but there's something
about this game with the abilities
and and engaging it and like covering a
flag carrier with as a Titan like the
the Dynamics and like teamw work are
pretty strong or stronger in this game
yeah oh
yeah and elimin a [__] um I want my
Titan butt yeah I call him
Ronin I'll call in right here and [__]
this guy up most people don't really
know what to do when you have a ronin up
close Okay this myip person it's yeah
it's two rounds of 12
bullets contr to Pilot get out of here I
don't
think thanks Sam
dog good
enough tone dude look to your left oh
man all
right oh a that's tough that the that's
where the phase Dash is tough oh yeah oh
oh nice oh I killed the Pilot's still
there so that Arc wave you send out can
like stun Titans like back uh once in a
while which is great cuz you know your
whole goal with Ronin is to like close
in and get in that
Grill
tight [__] you get out give me your
soul give me your soul is a pilot dead
yeah he's dead oh can't get out of those
oh [__] all right I got to let's get out
of here [__] go go go I'm not going to
be able to do anything against oh we
kill the Titan oh the Titan just
chilling there oh so well I don't know
if you want to get it now cuz there's a
Titan there but looks like there's a
battery yeah I need a battery really
badly also last time I told you to get a
battery didn't go that well so I got a
lot of money though oh you should cash
out oh you got to cash out yeah yeah
yeah if there's a dude in here waiting
for me yep yeah and a battery and a
battery get his battery r I'm all about
batteries oh he took it it's all right I
got a lot of money there and I took his
that was your battery I don't care about
the battery where where did that droning
go [__] I have Auto I don't Auto he's
he's done he's he's
dead yep oh give me I don't need the
battery took it he had a lot why didn't
that oh my God [__] [__] [__] he had a
dude he had like 800 bucks I should not
be in the open right now that's too late
now uh-huh that's a good that's a good
move where the [__] did he go he's
around
here I doubt he went through or he's
above you I can hear him moving
around yep ah reloading of us we can do
this wow I've never seen that much cash
on a guy he have8 over 800 yeah [__]
wow [__] so again if you're tuning in
this is Titanfall 2 multiplayer we're
playing bounty hunt
on PS4 the game comes out seeing people
in the chat say it it is coming out in
like 9 and 1 half hours for most people
or earlier I would
say I still have a decent amount of
money yeah to get out of here you could
I mean you might as well do some work on
those oh that's a
guy yep stand a
chance uh yeah I've got a decent I could
I mean I don't think you should wait
that whole that b
uh that b uh drop zone is like still
yeah very much
untapped I don't want to lose this money
though I have a lot decent
amount yeah you you had a
lot I mean someone's there you got some
enemies here for sure yeah
I know oh there's a guy yeah the pilot
in
there oh
yeah oh there he
is that's the dude that killed me before
he
had give me stem mother I need
stem yeah
ticks
[__] is there a bank around you have a
lot of money no uh no there's not a bank
around here kind of off to the side um
there's one a little bit to the right in
that building miss one yeah that's
fine go upstairs if I can get
there now hold it hopefully they just
clear out that drop zone so I can no
one's really like no one on our team
looks like there's a tighten over there
though I don't have
mine come on finish it's almost done
just kill them so I can get this money
in the
bank see that's the thing I would
normally go over there but I don't want
to risk losing this 800 bucks or
750 don't it's about no I turn back
around it's it's literally about to
end come
on come on come on this will put you
guys on the map yeah if I can should I
have tick I should have save those tick
to cover me while I there we go come on
come on come on
kill him there like one more dude [__]
someone right near me too oh don't get
in
there come on come on come on come on
come onor is remn open open
open you're on your
to I would go now run to the other bank
yeah steal some [__] yeah all
right like you got guys here already oh
ooh is this an enemy no that's your
bud get
there where's the other bank he's right
there yeah
yeah let's wait for
them damn they okay we're ahead someone
else had a decent amount too like 300 on
my team we can still catch up don't lose
come on uh man it doesn't seem like
anyone else is going to cash out this is
tight this is a tight game uh we're both
dude we're both close oh they're at 47
damn someone else so you got to go for
these B bounties you you almost got your
Titan
too [__] all right go this way no I
don't want to go that Pi where's this
Titan at over here yep to the right get
to this guy to the right I don't have my
Titan though you will very shortly
uh-oh you should go for that Bounty I
don't I with what I have a pistol oh
[__]
my just need a few more ticks on your
Titan you you'll get it now there you
go right in the
middle a they got
it close one wait how they deposit it
though you still uh rake up um Team
money as you kill or do
anything it's not it doesn't just mean
cash or cashing out at
bank get up
F Sport does look like a big daddy from
Bioshock
yeah oh man that a close
game see what my buddies are
doing
n oh he the last no sniping what's this
D
doing fun
stuff that might go
down oh he got
it wow all right uh you want to play
sure all right over
previously unlocked oh look at that so
did you hit Level Seven you must it
right so it's kind of a smart move also
like I mean it's too late now
but you know you think about like saving
your money like if you're if you're
about to hit level eight like double
check on what you're buying cuz you
might just get it automatically in like
one
gameit if you really want to be
conservative oh we got a new Banner
banners that's
great uh cool thank you for doing this I
like shotguns mhm got a scope on
here
great uh I'm going to do
cloak and I'm going to do the shotty I
want have this one beefed up
uh what time we going till about like
noon
maybe another couple
matches yeah maybe
12:30 I cannot go that long but okay we
have another stream at 1 with
stuff right not in here what's uh what's
going on at one uh actually is it a live
stream uh we're playing we're playing a
dishonor 2 with Harvey Smith like the
lead designer on
it um so that'll be fun and then sounds
fun actually I'm go with a pistol for
this yeah cool I'm excited for that game
yeah for sure that comes out the week
before Watch Dogs too the week after
Call of
Duty is the
season
yeah this is a dope ass pistol 50 50
clams damn
damn I'm not a fan of this level no I
it's pretty wide open I like it I like
the idea of it oh no this the one with
like like the bridge yeah it's got this
fat bridge and it's super hard to like
Trav like you have to get a lot of speed
in order to like clear it yeah and if
you don't you're like stuck on the
ground it can be really frustrating uh
I'm going to change my Titan to a nor
Hisar sniper SL missile jetpack he's
probably my favorite Legions up there
but I'm not very good with Legion I got
to get better at him
uhle the let's do
your all
right
nice gun's classic yeah it's like such a
safe bet do these sniping points ah
especially that Central Building if you
know what I'm talking about with the
second floor
yeah hi ooh get out my face
ah nope that's not going to work out is
it he's probably going to come for
[Music]
me over there
yeah this map is totally uh I I like
this
map
nice nice ow ticks I love just throwing
ticks around a front drop down or just
randomly into the street go forth my
child wait wait look at him slowly
crawling that grunt oh no that's that
dead look how [__] lonely he is um oh
there's a guy right near you yeah oh
[__] couple of guys couple dirty guys uh
nice yeah I don't I don't use the
grappling hook often I uh you know
during the open Beta like huge advocate
of it a look at this butt
head even as far as to say like it was
like all I wanted to
use
um using a Titan nice [__] this that's
bold
the entire other team knows where you
are now I know right like that's the
problem with those energy weapons is
like you are
just [__]
damn ooh uhoh uhoh uhoh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh he's right there oh
he's still
there who's sniping
me upload those
creds kill those guys trying to do the
same o got a Grenade oh you got him you
got him oh got I think I just killed
myself
yeah oh I should have spawned as time
how many maps are there uh about eight
yeah I forget it depends on the mode
there are some that are just certain
modes I think uh but yeah I think about
10 or so and then uh rob you were just
saying that all the DLC is going to be
free just updates I heard that today huh
everything interesting cool that's
crazy uhoh oh [__] this is
I don't like this match up ble
that right so norstar is the sniper you
want to like keep distance and
everything ooh another Titan what that
tone no it's a ronin keep your distance
blew it on that
rocket yeah cluster oh you got a gy on
you I'm sorry bud oh nice so watch this
here we go nice oh you know what I just
[__] did I just took my own
teammate's
battery oh someone's on you is no it's
you I think it's a buddy yeah oh there's
a guy right underneath you too in that
building yeah to your right I'll shut up
you're fine that was pretty rude uhoh
that was pretty
hilarious I should go for this
bounty yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
have not landed one of
those oh you're so exposed when you do
that but it's so get the drop on to uh
that's a ronin oh nice good
Dodge nice nice I get that guy oh he
dashed
ooh you got your you got your flight
core if you want it if you want it I
want
[Music]
Ito oh give it to me give it to me get
the Bounty too no way no way oh just
[__] him up is that a is that a ronin
yeah nice you get the
Bounty come on oh you're close ye
dude oh he waiting for
it damn I thought I was doing all
right uh yes house on Twitch was asking
how long single player campaign and how
is it for their first shot at it uh it's
about 4 and 1/2 hours and it's really
good the writing is not great but it's
it's fun it's it's really yeah if it was
any more campy it it would be annoying
yeah but it's uh it's very fun it's
welld
designed yeah like 4 and a half five
hours um depending on the difficulty
like we were saying we'd recommend even
if you're like not even if you're kind
of green with Shooters I would
say
uh try on a hard
difficulty just punch somebody Christ I
got to cash out this is where I always
screw up on this game or this mode oh
it's no don't get out damn it be careful
I mean play Northstar like you would
anyway kind of reserve a little bit
behind the
scenes
damn we
go so yeah I have a load out on this um
oh
hi oh what's
up cool oh he's rodeo
in get off of me you have you have anti
yeah you have is that yours he took my
you have electric smoke
just get it
back nice that was was a brief
exchange oh [__] you got to Shield
before you self-destruct
[__] uhoh nice those cluster missiles
are perfect for GRS yeah they
are I thought you I thought you hit him
oh there you
go
man yeah I'm about to be done wave that
I got to play it safe I also got my
flight core
ready yeah
get the sound effects are so freaking
rewarding like every weapon just has
like a its own little click
or
uniqueness like I love the charge up of
this yeah like it sounds like a
clock
cck should save
that your Shield's still pretty
intact yeah got some money I
needed uh-oh show them you will die
nice and I just keep going oh no dude
out yeah oh [__] please
God get a bank oh
god
oh there's a bank right near you if you
just there is one right there huh yeah
I'm chilling this building sucks
nice oh I just took 500 bucks no that's
your total I know say holy [__] was
making sure you didn't think
that all right
money
maker and
flash flash with cash uh I think there's
a dude going to the bank you set oh
yeah in this on top of the building at
least well he should come out and
hang come in my
buddy yeah I think I think my buddy got
him a battery right there if you I amped
anything oh you're right got you out
tight nice
oh mama yep
correct kill him [__] is he on top I
think that was his Titan
no got him no kill the other pilot
dude's
cloaking when you unlock the class with
the shield later on for pil looks kind
of like the cloaking class it up mhm
nope damn it the grappling hook takes
some getting used
to
yeah probably crank the sensitivity up a
little
more I like high
sensitivity
yep get him
guys a almost got that
Salvo [__] oh damn I slid there truth
and Justice got
you that's like what a Boondock Saints
reference is it I haven't seen that
movie in so long and you get youran
thanks uhoh I'm getting
pinged
sh we've not gotten PC codes yet have we
no stand oh sh yes do it watch Wait
watch it see it happen yeah oh it
doesn't give you the
kill H
whatever [__] love that a robot Falls
from orbit and [__] you nice ah someone
else got him damn he threw up that
Shield [__] at like the perfect time
that pilot got that yeah kill him take
that
Bounty cluster misset [__] I I got to
shut up sorry come
here yeah took his bone ass couldn't
land a damn shot uhoh oh
[__] so I am not in a good situation was
that a
Scorch yeah no it's a tone
damn it I can't land
those I almost feel like they're I'm
trying to use them like Ton's Salvo
Rockets or his like yeah it's more like
a laser though I
am dude if that dude knew what he was
doing he just throw up a shield and [__]
you up right
now show yourself
rein he's in the canal
I got a little bit nice oh oh see look
at that yeah that's good oh [__] oh
man yeah they know they got you oh
[__] yeah you guys are screwing them up
but that's so that's so freaking cool
that's like that's the beauty of this
game is like tone throws up a shield
well I got my counter yeah it's VTO
right over
him
yeah look at this so a good tone would
have shot a good a good tone would have
shot oh he just gave you a battery oh
look at that teamwork guys I love it
there you go you got this nice so a good
tone would have uh shot the sonar thing
at you to get that first lock on that
dude didn't know what he's doing though
yeah
God I love this game oh yeah stargaze
this one's a little easier to stick with
because the progression system uh the
Titans themselves are a lot more fun to
learn it's not just like light medium
heavy
loadouts uh just in general you start
finding more nuances the more you
play in general I could see this game
going a lot longer than Titanfall one
yeah I I I really do think
so just where's your money oh it's
abog
oh look at this right yeah we played
Xbox One and PS4 they both worked well
what I'm do see
yet come on it's not it's like not as
accurate if you don't charge up I don't
think it's like a drop
almost all right ready for this I'm
going to I'm going to use my tether trap
on him and then flight core his
ass
sick oh he's about to get out no he's
not never mind Spartan Pan's dumb
no I'm just
kidding man can you imagine
if where's the uh ship all right nice
damn that guy got 35 kills [__] that's a
lot of
kills I made more money than him though
and that's what really
matters that's all that ever matters
yeah you're right the accuracy was
really weird I I don't know like my
Crosshair was freaking on
him whatever like a weird drop yeah
whatever you almost I think you caught
up to me now or at least like after the
review event obviously for the review
event we got to what level
like I don't know 20s mhm
oh that's pretty cool looking
yeah you look
like so wonder why I unlock this 11
okay who is who should I know who gam
Sager
is yeah I was about to say that Eric Tay
is
uh I think maybe it's a YouTuber or
something got some grass
here oh is it a YouTuber I have no idea
lstar is pretty cool we can show
that what else is there uh cloak I want
use some of
that oh I want to look at my Toton soy
Toton
look that one's good for like Ronin
because you're right next to people
right but I also would rather do the
dash too I'm I'm all about the dash this
is just play steals play Styles yeah I I
yeah I think the dash is really valuable
for Ronin who is all about
like you know like just like circling
someone and and hidden yeah hit him with
his
broadsword man I really want some of
these all this is what I want I want
that so bad
or a butterfly I want those Red Baron
Ones from
one that's cool like that's like the
World War II like R your bomber type
stuff I love
it pretty nifty oh there's a scorch
one look at how the teeth like go right
around the opening of The Hatch oh yeah
it's like almost like he's eating the
Titan isn't that great
sick
oh
damn so people are asking you to try
another mode but we've been having
difficulties getting into them because
for whatever reason there's only like
700 people playing this game right now
we could just do it should we just try
try attrition I guess maybe more people
are in the network
now let's take a look at all the all
these uh customizable like one person
backed out and screwed it up for
everybody in the Bounty Hut playlist
F so this gun is is real
hot was that oh yeah we was that uh the
review event
right uh yeah it's real fun it's how do
you say it it's like some sort of four
round burst Grenadier weapon it's like
an energy weapon looking thing too
reading the Cold War that's a sick
name yeah right the arms race H yeah I
use that one softball's
cool EPG
is
dope
I can't wait to unlock a lot of these
things um we're not jumping to dishonor
2 directly after this rayin we
are I don't even know like I don't think
it's a live I don't Dishonored I think
we're recording I don't think it'll be
up today so um you have to stay tuned
got a few things to record today later
could pimp could pimp a couple shows I
guess got dead air the podcast the
horror podcast that you're on every once
in a while resident can evil when Mary
Kish and I are playing through the
entire Resident Evil numbered
entries uh yeah Designer 2 I'm not sure
when that'll go up but yeah I'll be
playing Harvey Smith and I are going to
be playing the game and he's going to
walk me through some new stuff before
that game releases on
November 11 10th or 11th cuz Call of
Duty is the 4th on Friday I think
Dishonored a week after so the
11th I could be wrong about that
actually I'll search that right now on
why not yeah if you're tuning in to us
right now we are playing Titan 2 uh just
2 release date is November 11th right
and then um Watch Dogs 2 is
November isth is November 11th like
wasn't that the Halo day it's Veterans
Day
right didn't Halo used to come out on
November 11th all the time feel like it
did Watch Dogs 2 release date November
15th that's a Tuesday after all right
this isn't working we had more luck with
bounty
hunt man we should have just yeah
Veterans Day November 11th thought so
cool yeah everyone's playing bounty
hunt oh you have enough people to jump
in right now at least for a 4v4 which is
good play one more before I got to boot
okay out of here you might have I don't
might have time
after yeah one or two
more ah this game is
fun
is there going to be a midnight release
for this game uh yeah I would assume
so I
mean I don't I can't speak to like
retail stores plans but I'm assuming
they're going to do that we're not
associated with them at all in any way
shape or
form yeah if you guys want to see um we
got a couple more games in here if you
guys want to see anything else uh may it
be Titan or ability I'll probably do
cloak next for pilot
um yeah I don't like this
map this map's good for CTF I think oh I
actually really like crash site um I
like it for last Titan
standing yeah for Pilots it's tough um
right because there's only like a a few
areas of like traversal like a lot is
just rock yeah what you siing oh you on
Legion yeah I'm going to try uh Legion
I'm also so they're rated on like one to
three stars kind of like hero Shooters
do it or moas do it I think legion's a
three star Legion and uh Scorch or ion
no I think it's
Scorch okay cool this this gun's good
too yeah I want to show this gun cuz
it's
freaking
crazy I'm already going the wrong
way oh yeah servers will definitely be
up in Midnight um before that right for
like New Zealand Australia people nice
oh this a direct
hit uh yeah I believe so yeah and this
this weapon doesn't have any ammo it's
just all cool down
[__] this
guy I kind of like grapple better for
this map too just cuz there's like what
feels like a lack of TR traversal
like
guys
there whoa how are
you yeah we're playing on PS4 for those
look
that oh guy was
ped yeah gild this one tier sorry if I'm
butchering that this is a PS4 we
reviewed it on PS4 Xbox One we have not
gotten PC codes yet uh we'll update the
review and what not to ref like that
once we do though oh that was that was
game
Sager that was a dude got 35 kills last
time that's
right remn Fleet forces Marcus Johnson
says do something
fancy
that gun's tough to use on this map I
I'm sticking to this
sorry do it
up perfect that dude's using
stem yeah he used stem pretty well right
there shut
up I'm still warming
up ooh
dude you got
him let's show what uh whatt leg [__]
yeah you might want to just go short
range with this the whole time right are
you on long range yeah you're on short
range
already oh I got him with that so that's
the
shotgun come here so yeah legion's cool
because you s right now he's in short
range mode believe it or not it's wider
spread but I think more damage for the
bullets um when you go into long range
mode obviously it's better for longer
range but you also get an R1 attack for
both of them when it's it's like a
shotgun thing when it's close range and
it's this like line rail gun when it's
long range that'll hit anything in its
path so now he's in long range and he
has the shield
up um then your alt is pretty crazy it's
just like anybody on your screen will
get a lock on and the bullets will just
start I have it ready right
now it's really good for against grunts
I wouldn't not best for one on one oh
on got my left yeah damn it damn it damn
it oh you're getting Rodeo too a ooh
tone Oh this one's cool yeah I really
like that one didn't look good in that
rock
yeah
uh-oh
uh-oh that went
well
I was kind of outmatched
there hi
guys whoa oh I put an upgrade on it just
charges quicker it like doesn't it
doesn't
charge that's what's weird maybe it
maybe that yeah ooh
ooh nice tight what'd you get 60 bucks
oh
Fu uh yeah the smart pistol is in the
game it's uh in multiplayer we can still
thing yeah in multiplayer it's an uh a
boost for your pilot so it's kind of
their ultimate you'll uh right now Rob
has amped weapons I think or no you have
ticks amped weapons you have amped
weapons so like once you charge it up
you'll uh you'll get that he doesn't
have smart pistol equi right now though
no that's that's a that is a 30
something yeah it'll take a l on a while
to do that oh that worked out yeah soon
saying upgrade allows you to shoot right
away but it's not as powerful trade off
I guess
reinfor [__] Indiana
joke Spartan Panda get out keep fighting
pilot your Titan's almost
ready there's an
weapons there's a guy there uh
anti-titan weapons are not great against
Pilots uh this the laser is kind of hard
to hit him with and then the grenade
launcher is really bad at like medium
range uh that's for the other ones there
a couple here we go um oh
oh rack him up rack him up rack him up
you got
lean oh that
was come here my
boy oh that's that look like tone for a
second yeah oh
oh
you can really feel the range on the gun
like when you need to switch it yeah so
inaccurate at close range right do you
see him like there's nowhere to go
you're de oh someone's got you so
nard yeah oh man my shield already went
out oh man oh where you going he's
almost dead too
walk on those
dudes oh
touche he's really not ejecting is he
there he is did he
eject yeah I think he hit the ceiling I
might have that cloaking oh good call
yeah oh I got to I got to do this damn
oh damn you guys are get H you got a
decent
amount yeah play that objective damn
he's got no
dash yeah the smart pistol is in here
it's a it's a boost for your pilot later
on like a level 30 something is Boost in
multiplayer oh the AR core or ar
grenade I got to get out of
there this
guy got
down and eliminated let's do this
nice [__] knew that was going to
happen I know I just don't like this
map no and there's a guy shooting at me
he's going to kill me in a few moments
down got a
battery I did I'm going to go for this
guy
again uhoh he's on laser core not
good
nice yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah one
more grenade give it to me give it to me
give it to me give it to
me no he's going to take it let me get
it [__] a [__] a
[__]
yeah swooped in on that one trickle down
Titan killing
uh-huh and you got Legion where's my boy
it's over here he is far away you
dropped him oh that was weird uh he just
ejected on this he's in
here oh did he above
me ah
[__]
I'm not playing this mode right I keep
forgetting like what I'm actually
supposed to do
Legion come here
baby oh another Bounty oh perfect timing
babe oh he's on top of me
huh
nice there you
go
oh come on come
on
nice nice nice
nice
F
damn
[Laughter]
damn I love this game so
much still got a decent amount h i mean
it would have been better sh don't don't
I shouldn't patronize
you shut your mouth hey we actually kind
of had a little bit of comeback here
only another 300 come back
wait where you
going
CH like now that I think about it
legion's alt is kind of like the smart
pistol on steroids yeah yeah good call
just a Minun oh these guys
Reapers
a rubber burner so you were saying the
weak point is their stomach right yeah
kind of like the Vex and Destiny I
guess yeah
right oo
nice
dangerous
yeah nice oh
man uh
nice you know I for I forgot is that you
can hack
specters and yeah good call I always
forgot about
that
what you not hear what I said you can
hack specters spe yeah remember that was
in the first game you can do that so you
hack them and then they're on your side
oh you have to come up behind them in
melee right oh gotcha [__] him
up [__] him
up nice nice nice oh he's going
up see I should have switched but yeah
you wouldn't have had time I he didn't
exactly the timing is like dude did your
is your
bullet uh what do they call
those your bullet belt or whatever it's
called Green as well did they change
that the
skin are my bullets green like look oh
yeah I I I changed that you can change
your uh weapon skin right I knew that I
just didn't know it affected the actual
like bullet the
drum the
drum yeah the the magazine oh the
magazine
gotcha got some cash going
here [__] thing I like to imagine
it's like every barrel of the minigun
firing at
once each Barrel is shooting someone
different yeah well I got uh my core
ready too oh that's Aaron playing
theyve
got 67 57 oh they won God damn it all
right I'm going to do one more all right
I got to go but okay I'm going to wait
till the end of this
match yeah Show
Yourself D I'm
tired somehow playing this game
I can pick this butt head
off I got my core
ready let's let it whirl
huh get out of my way that's my own
ship H Ark grenade yeah I hate those
ni oh no I'm out of ammo come
here
[Applause]
yeah small
victories damn look how good I did nice
if only the rest of the team did too
Aaron blam bomb all right all right
you're out have a good rest of the
stream appreciate it thank you Mike uh
do better next
time wow so
rude thank you guys for sticking with us
playing Titanfall 2
multiplayer on
PS4
uh this game comes out very soon
tomorrow but roughly around nine hours
so I hear we're going to do one more of
these
now I'm all
about let's try that out uh if you guys
want to see um anything
else let me know real
quick can you still pick up Titan
weapons on the map no so uh Titans are
kind of just set in stone as far as
their weapon Loadout the only things you
can kind of change uniquely are um kits
uh some being specific to the Titan so
like Legion I just unlock something here
one more so I can start with a counter
an electric smoke counter measure to get
Titan or Pilots off my
back
um or I get like
specific
Titan uh kits here so move faster while
the cannon is spun so that's good cuz
he's kind of a
Slowpoke gun Shield blocks so these are
you
know this is kind of how you like cater
more to you um like I have this guy on
which is his um oh I don't have it
yet but this is a cool one it's like
your cluster missile is stronger um I
like prefer that over another tether
trap to slow down people I just don't
think that tether trap is that
useful but yeah anyways Titanfall 2 six
players out of 10 we're almost back in
it oh cool look at
that let that texture pop in
there doesn't look that
cool uh I got a skin here look at that
cool
wow tone okay I agree so with tone we'll
put on uh I don't know I old
these we'll do an extra
Dash don't have anything I can unlock
right
now but yeah he has like a um he's all
about locking on to other Titans so you
can fire a uh this pulse Echo well this
is a a kit but you can fire I think it's
called um what's it called yeah Sonar
lock which is basically like uh the
equivalent to throwing a um a pulse
ninja star is one of the um you know it
just reveals enemies on the map as well
as uh offers like an an easier lock on
to another Titan so like I can just beef
that
up and it sends out another pulse so I
can like be at a farther distance and
lock on to um a Titan easier which is
like what you need in order for his
tracking Rockets to
work saw Ronin ion and Scorch we've seen
a lot of already but yeah Ton's a good
choice we'll do that
cool cool
cool hopefully we play a map where I can
use
cloak like the smaller maps with like
more close encounter corridors I think
cloak is like
Prime
we got
Patches
great uh yeah again boosts I only have
two right now I could unlock oh man 125
merits that's a long ways
away I could probably unlock a weapon or
something let's see
here 100 yeah these are actually
expensive I guess the only thing I could
get would
be oh you can't purchase the weapon
slots early you have to have a um high
enough
level
oh H I guess any kind of weapon
mod um is level
requirement what other um abilities we
have and these are all really
expensive uh these are kind of cool so
this one is a it's called the awall
ability you basically throw
down a Deployable Shield that when you
fire through it like amps up your um
your damage output and other people can
share it and as well as like protects
you so that's pretty neat um I don't
know if like I would like it just
because I enjoy parkouring more I don't
like staying put but if you're sniping
that could be a
plus and I want this weapon the frontier
is worth every part of this fight
let's do
this all
right one
more elimin remle in the beare of rival
faction but keep your on the
prize Remnant Fleet reinforcements
inbound probably switch to cloak a
little bit I just grapple is so awesome
for this
map oh there's a
guy ah that gu's good
[Applause]
nope I want to get in here let me get in
there oh my
God
I saw a
guy saw
pilot ah that
guy let's try
cloak banks open 55 bucks tight oh
there's a guy
here got your money on your
youran oh Christ is it inside
yeah oh there's a guy
here another
guy o look at
that all right we got
tone we got
toone box two oh
there what oh he's give me a battery
please
doy
[__] all right take it I will find
you oh man it's not
good
that was a bad
run
ass
whoa the pilot was riding him and went
with him I wonder if that killed him he
didn't really show up after a
[__]
nice sees me than
open
oh a battery here get out
damn [__] damn
it
you're win team it
UPN Fleet reinforcements
inbound some grunt
kills
oh see if I can go for this guy someone
doesn't kill me right
now yeah I'm playing on
PS4 playing very
well uh yeah time ball too
multiplayer bounty hunt
mode oh was that all right is he still
here oh I'm going to try
this oh come
here
uh-oh come here yes don't hit smoke too
late take down damn
it
o that guy was really
close it's too far
away I'm playing one
more your lead
pilotone multile getting forced out of
here yeah we're
good oh oh
man
beautiful
wa seor a is clear of Remnant Fleet
forces
ye oh that
guy down and
elimin
all right this SP Tak on this
Scorch wherever he
is oh yeah get him get me on ah damn
it they're hitting us hard but we can
still win this
thing don't hit
smoke jilot
the the enemy has claimed a
bounty all
right yeah come in come in here dude
so I got that sonar lock and then I'm
allows me to
easier or more easily lock onto him oh
there's guy right
here oh man let's do
it oh touche threw up a shield right
before I'm out screw this
o got me that gu's good that's cloaked I
should have seen that
replay oh 216 good
amount oh [__] there's a guy right here
huh
oh
Scorch we're really taking a beating
let's turn this
around oh there's guy
here they got let it get out of there
come here
great move now take it down
ah
no pilot get to the EV
ship don't shoot the
ship all right
hey that'll do it thank you guys so much
for watching Titanfall 2 comes out
tomorrow um or in a few hours I saw some
people in the chat saying 10 oock I
don't know if that's specific or Eastern
or something that but it's coming out
real soon uh it's really fun I love this
game a lot um I recommend it to anyone
who is uh looking for I guess another
shooter but it's a blast um but yeah
thank you thank you guys for watching um
yeah stay tuned for Gamespot for any
more timeful content we'll be putting
out some more down the road uh but yeah
thanks guys and have an excellent day
see
you
for